in her 2016 concession speech Hillary
Clinton vowed to champion the cause of
women in politics I know we have still
not shattered that highest and hardest
glass ceiling but someday someone will
and hopefully sooner than we might think
right now well she clearly thought about
running again in 2020 no one in her
orbit wanted her to and so far she
stayed out but she seems to be
determined to remain in the public eye
and so this week Hillary Clinton and her
daughter Chelsea whose incredibly
impressive she went to Stanford unlike
you we'll be releasing a new book
honoring quote gutsy women the book of
gutsy women is filled with essays that
are reflections of our feelings about
these women what we think about them we
always need this book because we think
it's always a good time to be
celebrating and learning from and being
inspired by gutsy women it's been
exciting it's been frustrating I think
it's been particularly frustrating for
Chelsea I went I wouldn't trade you for
anything not even for a laptop Jaime
Bruce is the president of independent
women's voice and host get Timmy Bruce
on Fox Nation which is reason enough to
subscribe to the service since she joins
us today so Tammy explain for me if you
could why I felt physically nauseous
watching the clip we just played you
aren't the only one this is watching
these two women on their perch of
progressive privilege making a
determination about who is worthy of
being spoken about or written about you
know if if they had any cuts which they
don't they would write a book about the
greatness of Margaret Thatcher that is
undeniable it's clearly a political
position that they have not necessarily
agreed with but part of being a great
leader is being able to recognize the
value of other people but certainly a
feminism it's supposed to be about all
women and opening the doors to whomever
we want to become and whatever we want
to do for a living but of course they're
the as you've said throughout the show
you know you're talking about a lot of
people who are frauds right they're
there they're not what they say they are
and this is a good example of that
so of course they'll highlight people
that they did they agree with they will
not highlight Oh
like Margaret Thatcher or Melania Trump
who the entire feminist movement has
worked very hard to ignore
they are the Mean Girls celebrating
themselves so it doesn't take much guts
to be there and to experience and enjoy
your progressive privilege to have that
protection that largesse and to look at
to put your nose up and sniff at
everyone else but it's also messaged
Tucker about who really counts that you
will only count if they you know touch
you and decide that your person who's
worthy of their attention they are passe
they are of course an example of what is
not feminism and what women should not
become and that is why Hillary Clinton
did not win and we will have a woman
president and that woman will be
conservative and she will do a good job
being the president I think that I think
that's a prediction that is likely to
come true so really quick what's the
point of this I mean these are two women
who have had you know a lot of success
doing I'm not exactly sure what but they
made a ton of money they're rich rich as
hell they don't need this why are they
doing it do you think it is certainly
for the attention but you know Chelsea
is gonna need to have a job and she's
not going to you know want to work in a
corporation I'm sure goats somewhere
9:00 to 5:00 like most Americans they
expect Chelsea to take on that mantle
because you know they still see this
country as a company that they should
have been heritage and now they're
working very hard to make sure the the
undeserving those who do not conform to
the liberal agenda are pushed aside and
I think that this is more than anything
this is about Chelsea and of course she
will be disappointed Chelsea has the
potential I suppose of delivering but
only if she becomes I think her own
person and is and herself is willing to
challenge the status quo that her
parents and Democrats like her have
moved forward for now a couple of
generations she could be the one who
breaks out I would love to see that but
I don't expect it no yeah I mean she
would to Stanford and worked in a hedge
fund shop oh yeah brilliant Oh
yeah Twitter feets outside amazingly
revealing tell me great to see you
tonight thank you sir thank you very
much